hi Kelly thanks for including me in the
good neighbor campaign my name is Alison
Wong and I've been drawing some light
hearted comics around the pandemic to
provide a bit of a break and then use
for everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm a mom I've got a five-year-old and a
three-month-old so it's a little bit
chaotic here and in the little downtime
I have I've been looking for a positive
spin or humors take in the news
everything from hand washing and grocery
shopping it's recognizing those on the
front lines everyone's doing their part
and I feel like I have a responsibility
to help out in some small way even if
it's providing a laugh the comments have
been really well received and people
thank me for brightening their day I
really hope they do for you too for
those of you watching
let's keep us going join the campaign so
we can be good neighbors together
[Music]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going